Any day now.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is expected to sign a bill
that would put even harsher
restrictions on the LGBTQ commun
in his country.
Russia's upper house of parliame
unanimously passed it this morni
Now, the law would ban
Russians from all ages
from, quote,
praising homosexual relationship
or publicly
suggesting that they are, quote,
That includes
advertising, books, films
and any form of media.
But one Russian couple,
one prominent Russian couple
has been leading an effort to ch
the Kremlin's views on gay marri
They publicly shared
the news of their wedding
and have also protested
the war in Ukraine.
Joining me now
from Berlin is Intel's a God.
He is a friend of mine,
a journalist
and author of All the Kremlin's
Michelle, good to see you.
Misha, thank you so much for com
with us. You shared
you shared your
pictures of that
that special day where you marri
Michelle in Portugal.
You have left Russia now
and you are an expat
after protesting the war.
So you were living in Europe
with many other
fellow German
journalists
who are protesting the war as we
There we see pictures on that da
When you posted those wedding pi
you said that
we got married,
love, freedom, truth and happine
It's time
to start liberalization from you
What do you mean by that liberal
You know, actually,
we've gotten a lot of a lot of i
with our liberty in Russia.
And I think that that
we've got after the war has torn
We all have to think
about our own responsibility
and about our own guilt
and what what we should do
and what we could do.
So I think that is very importan
for any Russian.
And that was that
that was my wedding toast, actua
wedding day
when I suppose that probably aft
that terrible
war has started,
we we should not recognize
the Russian state anymore.
And we cannot recognize all thos
inhumane loss.
They they are voting for.
So so we
we have to set our own precedenc
So we as is Russian
civil society
that opposes the war
and is fighting against what
we should set our precedent and
getting married.
We are setting that precedent
of legalization of same sex marr
in Russia, of fear of future.
And this anti LGBTQ law follows
a similar law
passed in 2013
and for many people
at home
watching Russia essentially
lose this war.
Some are asking why
this focus on the LGBTQ communit
when there are so many bigger
existential threats
to Vladimir Putin's reign at thi
Can you walk us through why?
I don't know how else to describ
but other than his obsession
with the LGBTQ community
and tying it to the West specifi
Sure.
You know, I was
surprised you
probably that
there are a lot of rumors about
ranking Russian
officials to be to be really gay
but in the closet.
And we
we don't know
anything for sure
because none of them
has publicly admitted that.
But there are a lot of rumors,
for example,
about the chairman of the State
which is like the Lord in
who became the first time,
the first proponent of that
so-called anti-gay law back in
2013 and now is
the most ardent supporter of the
Besides, a lot of people
from Putin's inner circle are su
to be gays.
So it's very it's
what these are the widespread ru
I don't think that that those ru
about himself himself are reliab
I don't believe that.
But definitely for the inner cir
that's not
the it's not a sin and it's not
So it's it's quite obvious that
they are
privately okay with that
but they consider that
it's very it's a very cheap,
cheap way, cheap
an easy way to get the approval
huge masses of Russian populatio
They consider Russian population
to be very homophobic.
And they are like that, that law
Yeah.
Very homophobic and
and very conservative.
And you talk about this whole
that the Kremlin still has
over propaganda
in the media,
but you as an expert on Putin's
inner circle
say that
that may fool the Russian public
but it doesn't fool
the inner circle in terms of his
Now, given that this war is not
at the speed
that he had hoped
it would, to say the least,
you think
he's vulnerable
right now, Vladimir Putin?
Mm.
I think his mother he's asked
why he's more vulnerable than ev
because especially after
the retreat from Harrison,
especially after the latest news
from from the frontline
it's obvious for
for the Russian bureaucratic eli
that he's not going to get away
with it.
So it's probably the first time
since the beginning of the war
last month.
It is obvious for a
for the inner circle
that he is losing, he's going to
And and
there is no way out for themselv
so probably they are thinking
for their personal ways to
to escape their situation.
They are still voting for a vote
for any law he proposes.
They are still publicly supporti
But that's but his power
his power is it's close to that.
Yeah. His power is waning.
Listen, Mikhail, it's great
to have you on.
Congratulations to you and Jean-
Thank you so much. Take care. Th